دعوه واحده من الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب كانت كفيله بان تفتح باب جدل واسع
رئيس الامريكي السابق اعلن انه يتوقع
القاء القبض عليه الثلاثاء في منهجه خلال
مثوله امام المحكمه وحتى انصاره على
الاحتجاج رغم كونها مجرد توقعات من ترامب
حسب ما اكد المتحدث باسمه فان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق فضل ان يقدم على ضربه
استباقيه بالفعل اتت المرجوه منها
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق جون
بولتون نصح المدعي العام بعدم الاقدام على
اتهام ترامب الا ان كان متاكدا للغايه من
التهم الموجهه له لافتا الى ان براءه
ستسجل في التاريخ على انها كانت التهمه
التي اكسبته كرسي الرئاسه مجددا نائب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بينس اعتبر
ان توجيه الاتهام المحتمل من مدعي عام
مقاطعه منهات الى الرئيس
مقلق للغايه وستكون محاكمه مشحونه سياسيه
فيما اعتبر الرئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ان مدعي عاما هاتنسيء استخدام السلطه
ويسعى الانتقام سياسي من الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بينما حث السيناتور الجمهوري
لينزي
على المقاومه واخذ القضيه الى المحكمه
العليا اما المدعي العام في منهات فحذر من
عدم التسامح مع محاولات ترامب لترهيب
المحققين واعلن التنسيق مع الشرطه نيويورك
لحمايه المحققين من اي تهديدات لغه ترامب
في مناشده انصاره الوقوف معه ضد اعتقاله
اعادت للاذهان لغته التي استخدمها خلال
تغريدات حركت انصاره في احداث الكابيتول
التي ادت لاعمال شغب واسعه لا تزال
تداعياتها حديث الاوساط السياسيه
الامريكيه